لا حسم قريبا في بخموت لكن المدينه
الواقعه شماليه مقاطعه دونسك في شرق
اوكرانيا ما تزال اسخن جبهات القتال قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه اعلنت ان 15 قريه في
محيط بخموت تعرضت خلال الساعات الماضيه
لقصف روسي شديد وعلى الجانب الاخر اقر
قائد ميليشيا فاجنر التي تقود الهجوم على
المدينه بصعوبات ميدانيه امام مقاتليه
مرجحا السيطره على بخموت في اذار مارس
المقبل او نيسان ابريل ذلك يعني اخفاق
الحمله العسكريه الروسيه المكثفه في
الاسابيع الاخيره في تحقيق انتصار حاسم في
بخموت قبل الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب
على اوكرانيا
وهذه خار كيف في الشرق الاوكراني ايضا
تعرضت فجرا لهجوم روسي بصواريخ اس 300
وطائرات مسيره اصاب اكثر من 20 بلده
ومدينه في المقاطعه وادى الى حرائق واضرار
واسعه في المنازل والمباني وفق تاكيد
اوكرانيا التي قالت ان قواتها اسقطت نصف
عدد الصواريخ المهاجمه تلك الهجمات وصفها
بيان من الاتحاد الاوروبي بالارهاب
المنهجي ضد اوكرانيا وشعبها وتعهدت
المفوضيه بتعقب الذين يحاولون اخفاء
اصولهم او بيعها هربا من العقوبات كما
تعهدت بامكانيه استخدام الاصول الروسيه
المجمده في اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
على الصعيد السياسي يتعزز الدعم
الدبلوماسي
فبعد عام على الحرب وللمره الاولى وصلها
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي ايلي كوهين اكد
كوهين دعم وحده اراضي اوكرانيا وسيادتها
وتعهد بالمساعده والشراكه في اعاده
اعمارها كما اعاد فتح السفاره الاسرائيليه
في كييف لكن من غير المؤكد ان تبدد
الزياره غضب اوكرانيا المتراكم من تل ابيب
لتقاعسها عن الدعم العسكري طوال عام كامل
من الحرب بدعوى البقاء على الحياد